Have you ever heard
the greatest trick the devil ever pulled
was convincing the world he didn't exist?
That is exactly how an abusive relationship works.
The man is not gonna come up to you and be like,
hey, girl, I'm gonna fuck your shit up,
and not in a good way.
I'm gonna fuck you up. No,
they're gonna come up to you and be like, hey, girl,
you don't even gotta worry about that.
I'll take care of it.
Don't worry about that.
I got you, girl.
You don't need to work.
I'll take care of that.
They're gonna take care of so much
that what you don't realize is
you're giving away all of your power,
all of your autonomy,
all of your independence.
And then one day,
when maybe you wanna do something different,
you wanna just break out of the norm.
Who's in control at that point?
Who is the one holding all of the power?
Someone who truly loves you,
wants more out of you.
They want to inspire the greatness that they see.
They want to cultivate
the things that they know live inside you.
They don't want to have you
just this complacent doll sitting there.
You're worth more than that.
You have more to offer the world than that.
And anybody who doesn't want to see that
doesn't have your best interest at heart.
So just remember the greatest trick.
The Devil ever pulled
was convincing the world he didn't exist.
The greatest trick this man is ever gonna do
is convince you that you don't have to work.